okay let's go over the geometry that we
use so we crank read it tilted the body
right so there's this kind of curve you
see that and then it takes more energy
to try to lift this over to get it in
the fall so we don't do that we tilt and
then we start another rotation over here
so that this hip goes out now when you
combine the two okay so if we're here I
am but I'm gonna do that in one motion
not too bad so this is that part yeah
this is the tilt and then coming back
and instead of having these two big
circles or even bleeding them this way
let's look at what his center is okay
his center come up his centers kind of
experiencing this kind of force do you
get it
so this spot here is kind of
so let's do it oh sure okay so I have to
do that with his center centers I'm not
going to treating me Nagas head like
this because it did not so we're just
going to go here and that's not it you
don't have to bend over for me
you don't have to bend over okay well
I'm going to do that with his Center and
the worst thing you can do kids get
ready to go back just this on there so
we're going to make it very big at first
don't leave out please okay make it
center move
[Music]
you
so
whoa that's not enough I got a senator
now but if his Center comes forward do
you see that Leah okay so goofy like
that I gotta get a center to come full
you think it starts to he starts to get
low so even though he's not a tall
person technique it just gotta be done
I'm turning this Center
again
don't do anything don't do anything
[Music]
what do we see that's how his height is
low
his legs look forward center comes
forward now I just hate going mouth okay
so switch
so let's happening here is the part that
you're doing in a gross external
movement I'm doing internally so a lot
of relaxation if when I tense out we see
how you forcing her out
so there's a lot of relaxation
[Music]
so you so whenever he is touching that
part relax whatever is in conflict are
cruising and goes around it there's
another conflict don't know right no
you're trying to get up knock down so if
whoa and I don't get this Center to go
wrong that's where you have your ball
[Music]
this external so I don't want to yeah so
we have to learn the multi
so we came here and I told you who you
trying to tap me okay you see I see
right in front of them
what did you guys do you came like this
and then you enter but now you an exam
right so I have to figure out a
different way of not being here and I'm
reading this and then that takes too
long so we
[Music]
he's never really looking at me you see
there's a different base of support the
differences there's one and there's not
so I can't do it this way so I have to
stop doing it that way that has to be no
option but this cannot be an option
either
oh yes he still has the space and its
height dependent
got it do you find me then you'll meet
some people if the body is rotating on
the spiral everybody's going to be and
everybody else's fight sooner or later
got it so go in here you're not in this
go please go
over the top right did you see her have
no face did you guys see that okay so
she's standing up okay let's go